hello everyone this is away and today
I'm going to talk about a project that I
have been working for the past half year
which is called book ton and it's an
hour package for writing books with our
markdown so first I'd like to talk about
some motivation behind this package
actually I wanted to do this actually
two years ago but I managed to have time
to get some time earlier this year so I
started this project earlier this year
and there are some problems that I I I
want to solve and I have been a student
in the major of statistics statistics
for over 10 years and I I believe that
there are some problems that we we
should solve for books the first one is
that books should be much it should have
been much easier to write
technically it's I mean normally people
use like latex or words to read books
these things are either not flexible or
too complicated and there are too many
technical challenges and today I will
show you how easy it can beat you who
write a book and the second problem is
that I believe that most of the books
are just way too expensive and my idea
of price for the books are just like $10
or $20 and you know typically the books
that you buy when you are a student I
mean the textbooks are typically like
around like $70 or 100 or sometimes even
$200 that's just too expensive and I
believe we can count some cost in the
books
third problem is that the books
especially that the printed books
never interactive and the content are
not rich it's not rich enough
if if you use book done you will see
that you can have a dynamic content in
your books and which makes it much
richer to read and for example you can
embed interactive yzma widgets or even
interactive shiny apps right in the book
and when you read a book you can use to
interact with these widgets or apps so
you can just imagine that we all read a
book on for example linear regression
you can just fit a linear regression by
yourself when as you read the book or if
you read a book on like machine learning
you can just tune the parameters in your
models and see the output directly so
that that is just like a personalised
book just like personalized messaging so
you can be you can have your own version
notebook so it's very interactive and
it's the content can be very rich and
the fourth problem is that typically
books are very slow to iterate and so we
after you publish your first edition of
book you often have to wait for several
years to write it as the second edition
and I believe that's just a way to slow
and it can be much quicker to iterate
and I will show you how and the last
problem is that the books are often
written by like one person or a limited
number of authors and the feedback that
you get we write the book is very
limited as well so typically you your
publisher will find some reviewers for
you it's like three anonymous reviewers
and you only get the feedback from them
I and I firmly believe that you can
attract
a much larger number of contributors to
your book and you can get much much more
feedback on the book and I will also
show you how so so when you are thinking
about writing a book so you you may open
your later editor more words to write a
book and we want to buy a book the book
can be like three hundred dollars which
is too expensive and when you are
considering writing another edition of
the book you I guess you probably often
look like this you just simply give up
because there are many problems for
example anyway we need to solve these
problems we don't want these problems to
happen over and over again you need to
end that and for example if you if you
are familiar with latex you should
understand what I mean in this gift so
if you work with latex
you know latex sometimes that can be
very fragile even even if you change
only a little bit in your document you
layout you can totally screw up your
layout your figures and tables can float
anywhere in the book and it's just very
distractive when you when you write the
book in how about word I know many
people use word the word is good if you
write a few paragraphs and sometimes
maybe we have you met a few other
paragraphs and you feel very good but if
you write a long document like a book or
a very long report eventually it will
just blow up like this so we don't want
you to be in that situation so what I
would recommend is that you can use
Martin Martin is a very simple language
I I assume most our attendees today and
are reasonably familiar with markdown so
basically
if you are able to write emails you you
should be able to learn markdown and I
actually I have a personal award which
is if you are not able to learn markdown
in the basics of markdown in ten minutes
I will just award you $10 so Marta is
very simple to write it's just as simple
as this you just hop out
hop on the car and you're ready to go
and then we actually because markdown is
so simple it of course it has there are
some features for writing books that are
missing in markdown actually the
original reptile was designed for
writing HTML content and it was very
simple but we have developed a package
called our account which added two
powerful components to mark down and
makes makes it suitable for writing
articles and books and these two
components are pen doc in our so first
we added our to markdown which means we
can mix our code with your markdown text
so you can embed your computing right
into your book so when you write a book
or an article you can just embed our
coaching stare and you click a button
and the article chunks will be we were
just be executed anyway you will get the
output and you don't have to run the
code separately and copy and paste
results so we added our which means you
can do statistical computing data
analysis data visualization in your
document so that's one source of force
in markdown and the other component is a
pen doc and pen doc is a very powerful
tool for converting documents and it can
convert markdown documents to many other
formats
four 2's Janelle or two later tag PDF or
two ebooks and work even Word documents
in presentations so it's it's another
powerful tool so with our in pen doc
markdown can be as powerful as this so
it has a lot of force so that's not done
and the story has not ended there so now
we have broke down and just one sentence
summary of book down it's a tool it's a
very simple tool that makes you look
awesome because we write a book you know
we will tell other people oh I wrote a
book and of course you look very awesome
so book town is just that simple tool
behind you that makes you look awesome
so you can write a book with very simple
tools and so I'm just going to show you
some demos using poke down before that I
want to briefly explain the basic
structure of books so when you write a
book or a long report you you often do
not want to write everything in one
single armikrog document instead you
have multiple are marked indictment and
one are marked on document is is just
one IMD file so you have multiple I'm D
files typically each MD file is a
chapter so you have multiple chapters
and book Don can convert these multiple
chapters into a book and the output
format can be like PDF or HTML or ePub
epub is a format for e-books and
important I also extended some markdown
features for example
so as I said the original markdown was
very simple and in PennDOT Smackdown is
more powerful but it still lacks some
common features for especially for
academic writing for example it doesn't
currently does not have the feature of
numbering your figures and tables or
cross-reference your figures and tables
and I added this feature in in Bucktown
and I will show you examples later you
can also embed interactive content like
videos or HTML widgets or shiny
applications in your book so and you may
ask when the output is not HTML for
example if it's PDF or epub how can
these HTML widgets or so many apps work
and thus that would be a very good
question and the answer is that if the
output format is not HTML booked on will
just automatically take screenshots of
HTML pages in shiny apps and embed a
static screenshot in your book but if
your reader wants to know more about
these interactive widgets they either
taught you the HTML out photo of your
book or go to the URL of the shiny apps
to to interact with this interactive
content and one so that you can have
different styles in the output as well
and the the style that I personally like
very much is a style called get book
style and some people might be familiar
with this so this style was actually
borrowed from another open source
project called gate book so you can know
more about that from gate book calm and
we borrowed the style from them but we
replaced the internal markdown renderer
with
so they so basically that means we are
using panda to render the book instead
of their simple markdown renderer and
the gate box style is also very
responsive in terms of that when you
will read a book on like smaller devices
like on your phone the theme the layout
will just automatically adjust to the
smaller devices and there are also
different themes like lighter themes or
darker themes and I will show you these
themes nature and also you can click an
edit button to edit the our markdown
source document and there are other
buttons on the toolbar and let me just
quickly show you the example so there's
this example the source document for
this example is actually on github is
under our studios account
it's called book down demo so if they
are interested in trying that out right
now you can just go to they speed up
repast reading so this is just a minimal
poke down demo so as I said a book
consists of multiple RMD files like I
have an index and II that is the first
chapter or the home page of your book
and then you have like 0 1 0 2 0 3 up to
0 6 and these are our markdown chapters
so you have these chapters as as this is
only a minimal example these chapters
are just pretty much like one sentence
so you have multiple R&D files and if
you have installed book down
I uploaded both down to train just last
night so you might be able to install
book down from Tran if it's not in your
creme mirror yet you can just install
from github using dev tools you can use
install dev tools installed github our
studio time so that's how you can
install the package once it's installed
you you will be able to compile these
time D files into a book so there are
the minimal configuration is this so in
the index dot MD you have a site option
which is booked on booked on site then
the output option which is booked on : :
get book get book is just one of them
output formats in in bhakta so so that's
just a take a look at the get book style
first so another thing I want to mention
is that I'm using the preview version of
our studio now so it's 0.99 point
12:51 so that's a preview version if you
don't know where to download the preview
version you can simply google for us to
do preview version so the reason to use
the preview version of our studio is
that with our student preview version
you will see a butte a butte tab here
and there there's menu here this listing
the possible output formats of your book
in the first one is good book so let's
just click this beautiful button to
build this i'm d files into the gate
book format so this is the gate book
format that i just mentioned and let me
just walk you through
the layout of the kid book star so the
big the kid book output is essentially
some HTML web pages so each each each
chapter will be a single page by default
so you can navigate through the book by
clicking the navigation button at the
bottom it is the button is at the bottom
because my screen is very narrow
right now if if your screen is wide
enough you can see the navigation button
will be on the left and right side so
you can navigate to the second chapter
or the third chapter so we can navigate
through different pages and so on the
left left side you can see there's a
table of contents showing the chapter
titles and of course you can collapse
the sidebar so especially when your
screen is too narrow you may want you to
hide the table of contents on the left
then you can search in the book example
you want if you want to know more if you
want to search for tables in the book
you can probably you can just type in
that search box tab and you will see
that your key word will be highlighted
on the page so that's the search button
and here is the pattern for setting the
themes and font size of the book for
example you can make your font bigger or
smaller you can choose different font
families use serif or sans serif you can
set like white the white theme Sevilla
themed night theme so different themes
and as I mentioned there's an edit
button on the toolbar let me pop out the
web page in my web browser
so here's a an edit button and this edit
button does not mean you added the our
markdown source locally it's this button
is there for your potential contributors
when your reader clicks this button it
will take you to github as I said this
repository is on github your reader
clicks this button it will take you to
the our markdown source document on
github for example it will be very
helpful if your reader finds like a typo
in your in your book and he or she can
just fix that title and commit death
change and get up and send you a pull
request in case you are not familiar
with pull requests let me just show you
an example of progress so basically a
pull request
is that you
you can fork other people's github
repository to your own account and make
some changes and then send the changes
back to the original repository so here
is the repository of the book are for
the science by heavily and Garrett and
you can see many people have contributed
to to that book and the most is the most
common pull requests is the ones that
fix the fix typos and you can see many
of the pull requests have been has been
merged let me show you how the changes
look like so basically when you read a
book if you find some typos you can just
click that edit button and make these
changes and submit this changes back to
the original repository and when the
author sees your changes he can just
click a button called a merge forecast
to merge your changes
back into the main repository so this
little edit button I believe it will be
very helpful if you put your book in a
public place like we have a website
called book downtown org that allows you
to host your book online for free and
when other people read your book and
find some problems or they want to make
suggestions they can just hit this edit
button and it will take you to the Comic
Con source and you can make that
whatever changes you want and send the
changes back to the authors so that
would be a very interesting way to
provide feedback or help the authors
write their books so that is what I what
I meant in the beginning and the books
are often written by a small a small
number of authors but they should
attract attention from many many other
readers and these readers can touch you
to your book and so the last button on
the left on the toolbar is a download
button so the the get as I said the date
book starts basically a series of HTML
pages and you can download the book in
other formats for example PDF and epub
so let's go back to the View tab again
so so so you can build this book using
the deep book format you can also click
PDF book to build the same or markdown
documents into a PDF document
so basically box down we'll just call
the PDF book format and come in later to
compile the disarmer 2002 a book like
this
and see this is a PDF book you have a
table of contents we have different
chapters and we can have floating
figures and tables in the book so that's
the PDF output and we also have the
e-book epub ebook ebook we can render
the book to ePub and since I'm using
matte it's it opened the e-book in
iBooks so still the same content
different output formats and another
cool thing about this multiple output
format is that pretty much all the
features will work in odd output formats
for example when you have cross
references of like chapters or figures
and tables all these cross references
will work in in epub and HTML and PDF so
you don't have to worry too much about
your possible output format so that's
the PDF and epub output and finally on
the get book toolbar on the right
there's a share button so you can click
these buttons to share the link of your
book on your social network media like
Facebook or Twitter so that's the book
down demo and next I'm going to just as
because this is an existing demo and
people may let me ask what if I want to
start from scratch and I can also show
you how you can just an start from
scratch to write a book so basically you
can create a project from ask
you file new project and you can start
with a new directory an empty project
let me create a project under the
documents direct directory estates let's
name this the book directory as test
book so now this is an empty project and
I can put a number of our markdown files
in this project let's say the title of
the book is an awesome work so you
create a new are mapped on documents and
you just save that as index dot IMD in
this project and then in case you have
forgotten the the two options that you
need to set one is they are code format
let's use gate book as the output format
and that's another option is the site
option that has to be broke down down
fact so you save this because this is a
new project let me let me let me restart
this off context so that our studio can
recognize this project as a book let me
open it again so steal the test book
project and if you open it again now our
studio can recognize okay this is a book
project so it will show you a beauty tip
and now you can build this single
document into a book into the gate book
format oops
you may say that it's the chapter number
is weird here because I should have used
the top-level section header here which
means one single hash let's view the
book again okay so now we've got one
chapter so so it's pretty simple to
start a book right just set these two
options and if you want to add more
chapters you can simply add other
chapters so another armitron document
let's save it as in chapter 2 dot IMD
and you don't put on any please so a
chapter title is should start from a 1
single hash let's use the chapter title
rule hello world world okay let's just
leave Schubert care about here another
chapter that viewed the book again so we
have to Andy's so now we have two pages
in the book
so that's how you can start a simple
book just to repeat this these are the
two options that you need to set so
that's a simple project let's go back to
book down demo project again um there
are some details that I didn't mention
and I want to mention them here
so one thing that I mentioned earlier is
that you are able to label number you
are able to number your figures and
tables and the way to do that is that
the third chunks you know you will have
some a chunk labels for example I have a
nice thing for this whole chunk and then
if you are using book time you will be
able to refer to this figure using the
syntax backslash at ref in parenthesis
then the figure label which is feed
colon followed by the chunk label so
that's how you can refer the figures and
for tables it's it's the same so see you
have this in a knockdown source document
and you have the actual figure number in
the output and your figure is numbered
here figure 2.1 and it can there are
many other features and you can know
more about these features from the book
down documentation which you can find on
book down org so this actually will be a
printed book in the future let me just
walk you through walk you through some
features that I think very cool so
there's there's basic markdown syntax in
Chapter two and I'm not going to repeat
these features and one thing I want to
mention is that you you should be able
to write math expressions in your book
so you can see some math equations there
so that's just a latex syntax basically
basically you just write your math
expressions in a pair of dollar signs so
talking about math there's actually a
fissure in book time which is there is
an add-in so if you use book down
there's an add-in called in input late
at math you can get that from the arts
to do toolbar and this add-in is to help
you write your math contents in a visual
way so you know personally I really hate
reading a full screen of backslashes
especially when I typed at math you know
it's very it's very easy to screw up the
math content if you cannot see the you
could see domestic front expressions
visually so this our student heading can
help you type the math expressions and
it also shows you the source the latex
source of the math content so when
you're done you can click done and you
will see the math equation in your arm
account source document and you just add
a pair of dollar signs and there will be
a math equation there so that's the math
and we can you can embed our co-chairs
you should be very familiar with that we
can number figures and tables and
cross-references and you can also have
some custom blocks like sometimes we
want to write some notes or warnings or
information in your book so you can use
these custom blocks I'm not going to
show you the detailed syntax but I just
want you to imagine I just want to let
you know that this is a possibility and
I mentioned estimate widgets and shiny
apps so when the is the output format is
HTML you will see you will see the HTML
widgets live in your book for example
I'm using an HTML widget package called
DT here which can convert your date
frames and matrices into a table like
this in your book so basically you can
you can print a data frame in multiple
pages you can sort the table interactive
you can search the table so so there are
many many other is from a widget
packages that you can use and this is
just one of the examples and also for a
shiny apps so when your reader comes to
your book and they can just they can
just interact with certain content in
your book for example 1/2 I embedded a
shiny app here the app has been
published to shiniest and I also I just
include that URL of the app in the book
so now this this is actually live so you
can zoom in the Matt you can like
interact with the Matt you can see given
the tabs in this shiny application you
see the date the source data
or other tabs so that's how you can
interact with shiny apps in the book and
when the output format is not HTML this
will just be a screenshot see let me
talk a little bit about customer
customization so it's actually these
output formats I'm highly customizable I
just want to show you one simple example
let's say so let's just use a tag output
as an example I'm not sure how many
people have used latex document and
class called comma script and that late
let the attack duck in the class is
called SRC book and you may need to
install a tech package but anyway I just
want to show you how you can change the
style of the output just using some
simple options oops I'm sorry it's not
SRC
SCR let's view this book to PDF again so
it will be using comma script - to
typeset your book so you can see now the
style is different and just with a very
simple change you can totally change
this time the appearance of your book
and of course there are a lot of other
things that you can customize for
example for the gate book style we can
choose to you can choose which buttons
to show there you can
we made right for example you may
disable this sharing button and you can
hide this download button or set the
font size or font family in advance
there are many many options for you to
customize the book okay one last thing i
want to mention about work done is that
there's a function oops called publish
book so after you have compiled your
book you can call this publish book
function to publish your book to this
website book down org so currently it's
free for you to post your book and just
one simple car of this function and your
book will show up here so now we have a
number of books like the the book for a
book time and for the science efficient
programming program mean for their
friends and a lot of other books and if
you want to learn from other people's
examples you can start from here and
there are detailed instructions on how
you can get started with our studio and
in Bucktown dot org
okay Oh another thing now I should have
emphasized is that since you have
multiple chapters and just to save you
some time compiling the book the default
behavior of clicking the net button on
the RCO toolbar is only to preview the
current chapter so that means if you if
you if I in this chapter and you click
the knit button it will only compare
this chapter and sometimes this can be
confusing because if you only come how
this chapter other chapters may or may
not work they may they may not have been
compiled so in that case you should
never get to other chapters because
their content may not be correct so this
net button is only for preview purposes
so if you click this button it only
compounds this single chapter so that
can that may save you some time if you
have some time-consuming computation in
other chapters if you want to compare
the whole book always use the build
button here this will compile all
chapters so just one thing to notice but
they asked to do IDE yeah that's pretty
much what I have today and if you go
back and try out the book down package
by yourself you may run into certain
issues that you don't understand and
don't just don't worry because this I
just released the first version of book
down to Tran yesterday so I will not be
surprised if if there are still if they
ask you some facts or issues so if you
run into these issues please just fire
them to the github repository or you can
ask questions on
stack overflow with tank book top and
lastly if you can't if you can't
remember all the things I talked about
today you can just go back and check out
the website broke down down org and if
you want to send me any feedback you can
you can either let me know on Twitter or
github or find find my email on my home
page or you can contact our studio I
want to thank you very much for being
here one person asks how does one
reorder the chapters okay that's a very
good question
all right yeah that's a very good
question so so you have multiple MD
files here and the default order is just
the natural order that's why I named
this i'm defiance at zero one zero two
zero three if you want to reorder these
chapters there's a configuration file
called book down dot yellow so there you
can have an option named warranty files
okay yeah is this and a final option so
if you basically provides your own order
of this and events using this and the
file option in the configuration file
underscore down that IAM Passman asked
can cross references me forward
references and the answer is yes there
it doesn't matter where your figures or
tables are you can simply use the chunk
label with the syntax that I mentioned
the backslash at Raths you may generate
a figure later in the chapter and refer
to it earlier in the chapter and the
next one is can you use Python with poke
down and the answer is also yes
to use Python instead of back three
tactics with our we just use three
pancakes Python actually this is um this
is not perfect at the moment and we will
improve this in the future so yeah
actually
besides Python you can use many many
other types of languages like C++ you
can use our symmetry you can see code if
you use Fortran and also familiar with
Spanish you can use Spanish
so all these features come from new
directions right the next question is
regarding math how to align such a line
in the label equations in our mock down
or book down how to align and label
equations
I believe you can use the aligned
environment so even if this is converted
to known the attack output you the the
equations should be preserved for
example for HTML output you should skip
I'm not I'm not sure if I'm typing the
correct syntax here but I think the
aligned environment is in the attacking
because you use that in Forrester
notebook as well and for equation labels
you can just use this index
thanks let's label actually this does
not work very well in terms of the HTML
output if you labeled an equation you
can only refer to it in the current
chapter we cannot refer to an equation
in another chapter the next question is
is the syntax accessed at ref generic to
our maximum or only available in book
down and the answer is is only available
in broke down its yeah but actually
there's one thing I've gotta mention if
you don't want to use book down and you
but you want the feature of numbering
figures and tables and cross references
you can actually leave out this cite
option but you set the output format to
be HTML document 2 or PDF document to or
work dot win - so these formats are
designed specifically for the feature of
numbering in cross-referencing figures
and tables so these these are profile
formats for example the word document to
format is almost the same as the word
document format in our mock down but it
just added the feature of transferrin
thesis and the numbering figures ok next
question is is
Tufte book format supported and I'm very
glad that you guys are asking fantastic
questions and the answer is yes Tufte
book is supported in the if you want for
example if you want let me check the
function names if you want HTML if you
want HTML output for crafty books you
can just use Tufte HTML book from it if
you want PDF I believe is simply yeah
- or book - yeah so yeah you can use
tattoo next question is is book down a
replacement of get book or competitor
it's not sure how to answer that but the
only thing I can tell you is this gift
book is one of the output formats in
Bucktown and the only that the major
difference between get book calm and
book down is that the markdown renderer
is different so we we use conduct to
render market on documents and they use
I don't remember they use their own or a
simpler a simpler markdown vendor so
there I believe there are many features
as I'm using there for example they
definitely don't have the feature of
numbering figures or writing
bibliography so yeah the next question
is can you comment of differences
between this approach and using rates
the dumb
I'm the template from arm d4 mass
package yeah I saw read the darn package
I read it down format a while ago but I
haven't tried that and it looks very
attractive to me and but I'm not I need
to read more about it to tell you the
exact differences next question is there
a complete list with yellow options
documented somewhere and the answer is
yes it's documented in the book down
documentation in section number 1.4
and let me pick a shorter question what
is the possibility of using this in
conjunction with something like I Triple
E sure no they attack templates so there
so that we can write conference and
journal articles that's also a very good
question and the answer is that instead
of using book down there's a package
called articles also in the our studio
repository on articles and there are
several examples of using our mock down
for journal articles truck probably I
can show you a very quick example of
using like of writing a paper for
journal of statistical software let's
create a new document and documents so
this is just a normal document speed and
it's using the articles package to
compile this document and now you can
see you have a journal article and the
only thing you want to do is that you
have to you have to write a latex
template and as I said there are many
examples here so you can probably study
these templates and and then used
actually latex style and then you can
combine PHARMAC down with these journal
styles